joëlle garriaud-maylam pour le groupe
ump
vous attendez c'est à moi ou pas
non s'il vous plaît si vous voulez bien
poser votre question
l'assemblée nationale vient d'adopter
toute à l'heure l'article 2 du projet de
loi visant réforme de l'université
article visant la multiplication des
cursus universitaire en anglais
cette mesure est présentée comme visant
à accroître l'attractivité des
universités françaises mais c'est là une
profonde erreur oui nous avons besoin de
renforcer l'apprentissage des langues et
pas seulement l'anglais monsieur le
ministre
au sein de notre enseignement et ce dès
le primaire
nous devons viser l'excellence par une
réforme profonde de nos universités et
nous avons le devoir d'y travailler
ensemble mais c'est d'abord par la
qualité de l'accueil des étudiants
étrangers que nous devons nous améliorer
avec bien sûr des cours intensifs de
mise à niveau linguistique pour les
étrangers notre objectif en tout cas ne
doit pas être de faire du chiffre mais
de former les meilleurs ambassadeurs de
notre diplomatie économique et d'
influence le filtre de la langue est à
cet égard un atout pas un obstacle car
c'est aussi une ouverture apprécié sur
un espace francophone en pleine
croissance économique et démographique
soixante pour cent des francophones ont
moins de 30 ans le français est la
seconde langue en progression mondiale
après le chinois et nous devrions
atteindre 700 millions de locuteurs à
l'horizon 2050
au delà du monde étudiant c'est un
signal très négatif de renoncement que
nous envoyons à l'international et que
nos partenaires francophones ne nous
pardonneront peut-être pas mes chers
collègues
et comment ne pas nous juger
schizophrène quand nous encourageons
l'enseignement du français l'étranger
tout en nous exonérons de nos
responsabilités linguistique sur notre
sol
pourquoi financer un programme de 100
mille formateur pour l'afrique
si nous abandonnons notre langue dans
l'enseignement supérieur
que dire à ces jeunes qui font l'effort
d'apprendre le français dans nos lycées
dans nos instituts et nos alliances à
l'étranger dans l'espoir d'aller étudier
dans notre pays il ne s'agit évidemment
pas d'interdire tout court aux langues
étrangères à l'université
il s'y pratiquent déjà mais de refuser
l'inscription dans la loi d'une mesure
aussi absurde aussi négative les
hispanophones les us lusophones et la
chine redoublent d'efforts en faveur de
chocolat vous permet-il inde la chine a
créé en afrique une chaîne de télévision
merci 16 est-ce que nous allons
capituler monsieur le ministre si la
parole à monsieur alain vidalies strapi
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice je vous demande d'abord
d'excusés geneviève fioraso qu'est
justement dans le débat sur la réforme
de l'enseignement supérieur et je vais
vous donner les éléments de réponses
qu'elle a préparé mais je voudrais y
ajouter parce que la nature de votre
question me oblige de rappeler au
préalable que nous n'avons pas décidé de
modifier la constitution et que la
langue de la république restera bien le
français
j'ajoute
j'ajoute que l'article l'article 2 du
projet de loi a naturellement a
naturellement un s engager un débat
parfois dans des conditions assez
outrancière et chacun s'y reconnaîtra
lorsqu'on évoque l'abandon de notre
langue
après l'adoption de ce texte je rappelle
que le principe suivant lequel le
français la langue de l'enseignement des
examens et des concours reste et restera
la règle le projet de loi prolongée
précise des dispositions qui existent
déjà dans la loi puisque dans le droit
positif avant même la modification qui
vous est proposé il est prévu une
exception en faveur des établissements
dispensant un enseignement à caractère
international c'est le résultat de la
loi toubon que votre majorité avaient
soutenu l'article 2 est donc très loin
d'introduire l'anglais comme langue de
droit commun au sein du service public
il ne prévoit pas que des fois il ne
prévoit pas que des formations
existantes basculeront en anglais il
n'ouvre aucun droit à suivre un
enseignement ou à passer un examen dans
une autre langue que le français
trois raisons ont conduit le
gouvernement à retenir cette rédaction
pragmatique et encadré de l'article 2
d'abord une demande qui émane des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
elle figurait dans la synthèse du comité
dé pilotage des assises de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche et à d'ailleurs été reprise
par jean yves le déaut dans son rapport
sur la traduction législative des
assises ce sont les acteurs de
l'enseignement eux mêmes ceux qui ont
directement en charge recrutement et la
formation des étudiants étrangers qui
estiment cette mesure nécessaire la
deuxième raison tient à l'attractivité
de notre enseignement supérieur
la qualité de nos universités de nos
écoles constituent le premier critère
d'attractivité mais à qualité égale
certains étudiants issus de pays
émergents font de la langue de
l'enseignement un critère de sélection
est devant ce fait les établissements
doivent pouvoir eux-mêmes déployer la
stratégie de leur choix la troisième
raison c'est la nécessité de préciser et
d'encadrer un mouvement qui existe déjà
l'offre de formation aujourd'hui
comprend plus de 700 par monsieur
minutieuse dit l'interdît du derby
dispensés dans une langue étrangère
aujourd'hui il s'agit de promouvoir
l'attractivité de la france et je pense
que le débat qui a lieu ce matin à
l'assemblée nationale et qui aura lieu
au sénat montrera que c'est plutôt la
voie du progrès et qu'il n'y a rien
changé pour notre lent merci monsieur
jean jacques mirassou pour le groupe
socialiste